if god is a god of love why is there so
much suffering find out on this episode
of led live
[Music]
exposing darkness what's up everybody
thanks for tuning in to led live today's
show we have london lee who's doing his
series on the faith of jesus
take it away
all right so we are in the midst of
finding answers to life's biggest
questions and so one of life's biggest
questions is why so much suffering so if
this is your first time
joining us we've already answered the
question of man's problem and god's
being the remedy we've also looked at
the challenge to the church and how the
church has to step up and reveal the
character of god and we've looked at
this scripture uh here's the
here's the patience of the saints here
they that keep the commandments of god
and have the faith of jesus so we're
talking about what's the difference
faith in jesus and the faith of jesus
and so we also looked at jesus's love
for men and
we've looked at jesus and the bible how
the bible was the basis of everything
that jesus believed and so now we're
going to look at what was jesus
understanding of suffering you know as
we've traveled the world and travel we
number one question is if god is a god
of love why does he allow suffering
right all of us have had to grapple with
this with death and especially in this
time of covet and so
notice what first peter chapter 4 verse
12 says
beloved think it not strange concerning
the what fiery trials which
is to try you
as though some strange things happen so
peter
he knew a little bit about suffering
right he knew a little bit about
rejection and failure he's like don't
count it strange he says but rejoice in
as much as ye are partakers of christ's
suffering so notice the christian
suffering is connected to who's
suffering
jesus says if they hated me what's going
to happen to you
they're going to hate you too right so
that when his glory shall be revealed ye
may be glad also with exceeding joy so
peter warns us that we will have trials
we will have tribulations we will go
through suffering fiery trials intense
trials intense disappointments that will
attempt to discourage us from following
jesus do you know anybody who's ever
been discouraged from following jesus
because of the difficulties
absolutely and so why are not all of our
days sunny and full of joy and peace why
do you think god allows suffering in the
life of his uh uh children i think it's
because he's allowing free will and part
of that free will is
you know the fall and we got an enemy
out there so it's it's just because he's
he's allowing this thing to play out
exactly we're angry at the consequences
of our own choice and some may say oh it
wasn't our choice that was adam and eve
but we make choices every day that
reflect their bad decision back all the
way in the beginning right i think
sometimes when we go through those
trials and tribulations it it it awakens
something inside of us like
if i've always heard if we have
persecution in this country we'll really
see who's really having the faith of god
you know and and so sometimes those
things are are god's way of really
reaching on reaching our hearts and
bringing us closer to him so that's the
end result
you know it's worth it so some
christians say shouldn't the true
christians be free from sorrow and
difficulties see the christian journey
is not all sunshine christians are not
spared dark days so why does god allow
suffering that's what we want to answer
today and so
is it because of the disapproval of god
now this idea of bad things happening
because god disapproves or he's
punishing us has been uh coming down to
us for millennia right so is it because
of sin
oh it's because you sinned if you had
more faith then you wouldn't have got
sick if you would have done this or you
would have done that so notice what
first peter 3 3-9 tells us would you
read this for us scotty blessed be the
god and father of our lord jesus christ
who according to his abundant mercy hath
begotten us again unto a lively hope by
the resurrection of jesus christ from
the dead it says to an inheritance
incorruptible undefiled that fadeth not
away reserved for you where in heaven in
heaven who are kept by the power of god
through faith unto salvation ready to
revealed in the last days now notice
this last section wherein ye greatly
rejoice though now
so
the reward is future but now
for a season if need be you are what in
heaviness through what
manifold
that's many temptations coming at you
in different ways right
the life of jesus is so inspiring he
didn't stay in the suffering he died
rose amen and has his place in heaven
right and if we follow that same path
we'll be there with him right man and
even just the fact that he came to earth
and suffered right you know like that
just show like we're all on this hurt as
he as an example right and us being on
this earth he suffered just as we suffer
it says that the trial of your what
so the trials are testing our faith
being much more precious than gold that
perishes though it be tried what
with fire might be found praised unto
the praise honor and glory at the
appearing of christ so why does god
allow suffering
to test our
faith right you said it when persecution
comes
real christians rise to the top
and fake or those who are building on
any other philosophy in a relationship
with god they what they scatter can i
pause you right there for saying go back
to the previous slide i read that that
the trial of your faith and so faith
needed to be tested and that was true
since the garden of eden so
could it be said that it wasn't supposed
to be a painful experience it was just
supposed to be that of trust right
because not eating of the fruit that
doesn't really sound painful to me right
right i just i thought they came out and
you're right so
think about it satan and his angels fell
right there was a void in heaven god
created
humanity to fill that void but guess
what the unfollowed angel was like whoa
you're going to let like we got to have
checks and balances right and so god is
showing his love his character but he's
showing that he can produce a generation
he can produce
a perfect character in humanity again i
think love also has to be tested like if
i think about love in a marriage um you
know it's one thing to to trust and love
your wife to the point where it's like
you can let her go
have a job and go somewhere and you know
you're not just sitting there lording
over her and watching and controlling
every little aspect of her life like
that that to me is not love it's it's
it's when you give them the freedom and
they choose to come home and love you
it's like that's what god is doing with
us is he's got to allow us the space and
freedom to to choose otherwise if you
want to right right so it says whom not
you have not seen you believe you love
in whom though now you see him not yet
believe ye rejoice with joy unspeakable
full of glory receiving the end of your
faith so what's the end of our face
even the salvation of your soul so as
god is seeking to produce faith the end
right is the salvation of our souls so
notice isaiah 53 verse 3 it's concerning
christ and it says that he was wounded
for our transgression right so did jesus
suffer
right it was prophesied that jesus was
going to suffer it says he would be
despised and rejected of men a man of
what sorrows acquainted with grief and
we hid as it were our faces from him he
was despised and we did not esteem or we
did not value him do people still not
value the sacrifice of christ right it
says surely he has borne whose griefs
our grace and carried what
our sorrows yet we did not esteem him
stricken smitten of god and afflicted
but he was what notice why did jesus go
through all the suffering and shame he
was wounded for whose transgression
our transgression he was bruised for our
iniquity the chastisement of our peace
was upon him and with his stripes who
were healed
so jesus was prophesied that he would
suffer but why would he suffer for our
sake for you to heal us right and so
sometimes god allows suffering not
because you did something wrong
but it might be a blessing or a witness
or a testament to someone else
you know it says uh all we like sheep
have gone astray have we all gone our
own way
all of us have turned our own way and
the lord has laid upon him what
the iniquity of us all he was oppressed
now he's he's still writing why do you
think he's adding all of these he was
oppressed he was afflicted he was beaten
he was smitten he was hated what is the
author trying to communicate
i think jesus um experiencing
suffering and especially our suffering
especially when he doesn't deserve it
i think once again it's like our god is
willing to
to go through what it's like to be in
this human synthetic world
and
and it's like he's put himself in the
position to experience the utmost what
even many of us wouldn't even experience
right and it's like you know
people that want to like fight against
god and and say you know what has he
done for you it's like what has the
devil done for you he hasn't come down
here and suffered for you he's causing
him
right so it's like to me it's comforting
knowing that that wow my god is willing
to to just demote himself and experience
this mess that we are experiencing and
even worse than what i would ever ever
experience and so here isaiah is
describing right he was taken from
prison and from judgment right it says
for he was cut off out of the land of
living for the transgression of my
people with strict so he was made his
grave with the wicked so notice he's
going down down down it says he was uh
with the rich in his death because he
had done what
no violence neither was any deceit in
his mouth so notice paul in uh
philippians 3 10
he says
that i may what
know him and the power of his
resurrection and the fellowship of his
what suffering so to know jesus
we must
have fellowship
in what
suffering right being made conformable
unto his death
if by any means i might attain unto the
resurrection of this so he he he
connects the suffering with the victory
right and so they say there's no crown
without the cross
many christians want the crown of glory
but they don't want to take up that
cross daily and that cross is different
for each and every different person
right and so as we come close to know
christ right and to love him if he asks
me to suffer for him who's my example
he's like i suffered for you my son
and his suffering was infinitely more
than my own suffering notice what james
wrote james says my brethren counted all
joy when what you fall into the
temptations so so paul says don't worry
about it now james says guess what
you're going to fall into
temptation but guess what count it all
joy he says why knowing that the trying
of your faith works what patience
patience and it says let patience have
her what perfect perfect work that ye
may be perfect entire wanting that so
suffering actually is a process of
perfecting our faith
right and so now let's look at john
we're just looking at the what what do
the disciples believe on suffering john
the revelator revelation 1 verse 9 says
uh would you read that for us mikey it
says i john who also am your brother
and companion in tribulation wait did
john know about tribulation where was he
writing from from uh
he was in prison i've actually had the
privilege of going there and seeing the
prison and seeing it's it's it's a rock
like i took a little motor scooter and
went around you go around in like
25 30 minutes right there's literally
nothing there alcatraz right like
alcatraz right and so here he says guess
what he's writing to the church he says
i am your companion in tribulation and
wasn't he like the the last surviving
disciple at this point yeah like all of
them he was boiled he was boiled and god
preserved him they said whoa we can't
mess with that put him on patmos right
he says in the kingdom of patience of
christ jesus was in the isle of pat
called patmos now notice why was he
there for the word of god for the word
of god so why was he suffering
because he was being true to the word of
god and for what
the testimony of jesus and the bible
says in john
revelation 19 10 that the testimony of
jesus is the spirit of prophecy so john
was a prophet
and he was being persecuted for being
faithful to the word of god so is there
any other reason for suffering then so
we've seen that hey being faithful to
god's word
you know uh uh uh sharpening or or
testing our faith is there any other
reason for suffering
i think um misery likes comfort right
and and uh
when we suffer and we go through certain
things
and maybe we come out of that there's a
lot of other people that are going to
experience similar things like that and
so if we can kind of be a source of help
to those people i mean you think about
it they're looking for some reason why
these things are happening and it's like
maybe you've gone through that fire
you're trying to come out the other side
so maybe our sufferings and trials
aren't necessarily just
even just for our own i know the bible
says it's for our own faith as well but
what if it's also to help other people
right that's so good it gives you a
compassion for
other suffering people like
some rich dude in his bins see somebody
on the side of the road and drive by oh
man your car you got a you got a
terrible car and they just keep going
but me who's been broke down on the side
of the road many times i got compass oh
i know how bad that you know let me go
see if i can help yeah and i come over
hey man can i help you know right i can
identify with the pain there's an
example in the bible jesus and his
disciples are walking and they see is it
a blind man or a lame man on the side
and and the disciple says you know what
what sin did he commit why is he
suffering
he's preaching my sermon
it's all right that means the holy
spirit's working right and so as you
reference that yeah so what their
question was who sinned
so their understanding of suffering
was it had to be a direct result
right so
if so what is it right so we must look
at the life and teaching of christ for a
better understanding so but first we got
to look at job you just referenced job
right now we're going to learn some
lessons from the the life of job so men
have believed that suffering and
sickness were afflictions but
put upon men by who
by god because of sin right so what does
that say about god
what is that what picture does that
paint of a god
who will put suffering on you because
you didn't do what he asked you to hmm
it's like this idea that god's up there
just waiting for you to fall asleep
but when you have a child learning to
walk and they fall on the ground you
don't go in there and say that's right
you fell on the ground or start spanking
them yeah like what's wrong with you no
you have compassion so satan wants to
paint the most hideous picture
of god as possible right and so a
healthy man this is job was thought to
be a blessed of god right an unhealthy
man was thought to be cursed of god so
job's three friends had this mindset and
so job himself believed this too he
searched his heart so think about it all
the calamity that happened one after
another after another after another
after another if you don't know the
story of job you need to go and read it
it's fascinating and so here this
mindset is that is there any possible
way that i have caused this suffering
right
but it but he came up with nothing yet
god's displeasure was upon him this
troubled him greatly because it starts
out saying how upright right yes he was
adjustment right and so notice some his
friend said guess what you gotta have
some secret sin man we know that you've
been rich you've been wealthy you've
been blessed but man we finally knew you
was just like us that's hilarious his
friends were doing great you know they
were there supporting him and then they
had to open their mouths
yes
yeah
we can take a lesson right so all he
needed to do is what
let go
and and all would be well again job
maintained his innocence and integrity
before god so now let's go to job 13
verse 15.
he says what now listen in the midst of
losing his house losing his family
losing all of his businesses now he's
covered from head to toe with boils
right all the externals say you are a
sinner
and he says though he slayed me what
now we're talking about the faith
of jesus so job is a type of those who
will be living in the last days are
there going to be trials and
tribulations are people going to come at
us is the devil going to come down with
great wrath that you don't deserve right
that you don't deserve falsely accused
right it means shaking a bend i go right
he can save us from the fire but if he
doesn't right he's still going to stand
for him but think about this experience
right here think of all the people that
have read job and been encouraged well
they've gone through something so it's
like his suffering has helped how many
countless of thousands of people down
the road millions millions so but i will
maintain my own ways before him job 19
for i know that my what redeemer
so notice the faith and confidence he
says i don't i can't explain it but i
know my redeemer living and yet and that
he shall stand at the latter day upon
the earth and though after my skin worms
destroys this body yet what
in my flesh i might see god i shall
so notice the confidence that he had
right he says whom i shall see what for
myself and my eyes shall behold and not
another though my reigns be consumed
within me i love that and god's like oh
yeah let me go let me go down and talk
to this guy amen right and what was that
what was the accusation against job you
only satan said he only served you for
the loaves and for the fishes right let
me get adam let me let me let sickness
let financial problems let all of these
things right so job chapter one we see
it says that job was what type of man he
was perfect upright and he feared god is
there a message that talks about fearing
god giving glory to him and hating evil
so notice his children he worshiped job
one verse six he says now when there was
a day when the sons of god came to
present themselves before the lord and
who shows up
satan who should have been in that
council
and why was adam not there because he
forfeited he abdicated he surrendered
dominion to the world to satan so satan
comes up and they're bold oh i'm right
i'm rightly to be here because now the
planet is mine and so notice what jesus
says or god says
and the lord said unto satan where are
you coming from
right and satan answered the lord and
said where is where's he representing
her what's your hood
like where are you coming from he's like
i'm coming from the earth i'm walking so
who what does he claim
he claims the earth as he is so
revelation tells us there was war in
heaven we know that michael his angels
fought against a dragon and his angels
and what happened satan was cast out
where into the earth and so satan claims
earth as his headquarters right
guess what satan reigns supreme it looks
like he won the game of thrones right
so notice it says the lord said unto
satan now notice this is
incredible
satan claims the territory of satan and
what does god do what's the he says have
you seen my what
my servant job
right and that there is none like him
what
in the earth so job the bible says he
was perfect he was righteous he hated
evil he was perfect and upright and
upright man one that fears god and hates
evil and now notice the comeback what is
satan's argument yeah
there's a reason why he he trusts you
there's a reason why he trusts you right
it says have you not hedged him have you
not protected him from me haven't you
kept me from getting at him haven't you
and notice he says he says you have
blessed him and the works of his hands
and his substance you have creased his
land as if that's a bad thing you know
right
but notice was he blessed
was he increased but notice the argument
but put forth your hand
now
and touch all that he has and what's the
argument he will curse you to his face
so so is this still true today
you know also what's at play here is
sometimes we we look at the dynamics of
how this is just affecting us but we
don't understand that there is a much
greater thing at play here
the devil's really showing his hands
right here because he's taking somebody
who doesn't deserve it
kind of like evil done to him and he's
going oh yeah just watch watch let me
let me let me cause this guy some pain
and we'll see who's evil now right
so there's no reason and the lord said
unto satan what
behold all that he has is in your power
only upon himself put not your hand so
where does evil come from
satan where does heartache and pain and
suffering come from so everybody that
sits there and goes god is allowing all
this suffering he's the one that's pop
that's causing all this thing this is a
telltale right here of like why why
isn't the first go-to like aiming back
at satan right satan why are you doing
this so what if someone says well i
don't believe in satan or because like
you know god is the one who controls
everything if he's god
so
you know at the end of the day he's
controlling all of this using this story
going back to your question interesting
word he used control
permit is more appropriate because he
didn't control satan's actions i want
you to go and kill his children i want
you to go
so obviously someone has to work within
those parameters so you can't say a
being doesn't exist satan does exist
it's that god allows it and we see why
look at the ending
so what about in the beginning when um
where i believe god says have you
considered my servant job right
is is there a translation issue there
because it seems like god is saying oh
hey
check out job you should mess up his
life no no no no no i think god uses
everything right he's he's using job as
the last
point of purity see satan claims the
whole world he's like no no no
i
i have one representative on planet
earth and his name is job so you think
that you have a hundred percent no no no
no job still serves me so satan's
argument is like yeah yeah he serves you
but why well look the angel of the lord
and camper around about them you haven't
let me at him because he's righteous
because he's he's perfect he's mature he
trusts in you so satan's argument is
that
nobody can nobody can live up to your
standards god right and they only serve
you because of the blessings yeah take
away the blessings they'll curse you you
you know that's interesting because in
the end of the world that's really the
devil's aim is to have full dominion and
it's like let's take out anybody that's
on god's side so that the whole planet
is underneath our rule because you then
then it's ours and so that is sort of
the beginning of him
saying no i run this whole place and
god's like no you know he's trying to do
it all over the years like the coliseums
and everything so christian so i would i
would propose that the experience that
all human beings are having at this
moment
on planet earth is a part of that
process
the systems that are being put in place
the pressure
that is being put in place is to
to to bring forth that job-like people
that keep the commandments of god and
have the faith of jesus and so notice
satan now leaves the presence of god and
what happens
notice we're going to three ways that
satan
attacks god's people number one
so job was a righteous man so every day
he sacrificed for his children right he
had
seven daughters and three sons and they
were out doing what young people do they
were trying to live for god and so he
would sacrifice for them because guess
what he didn't know what they were doing
that they might have some secret sin
right and so the lamb covers the bible
says
love covers a multitude of sin
and so the first thing that happens is
satan attacked
oxen
and guess what
job had thousands of camels thousands of
oxen and guess what what type of person
back then had that he was a businessman
right the camels were like the the semis
right they were transport the donkeys
were workers the horses and so he was
running a large corporation and so the
servant comes in and says all the oxen
have been stolen
then fire comes down from heaven
destroys his property right kills burns
up all of his sheep right so sheep and
oxen then the camel's got
so all of these represent financial
crisis so the first way that satan
attacks god's people is what
control their finances because guess
what
if you can't buy or sell
right
if you can't buy or sell guess what
you're going to be tempted to compromise
you're going to be tempted to well you
know just this one time right so
it's the false security that our money
is our livelihood rather than god is our
system right right
so the first way satan attacks is a
financial crisis then
the next thing that happened he attacked
his family right the great wind came
right so now there was a family he lost
all his children in one city he talked
about
painful right i've heard there's no
greater pain than losing a child right
and i mean that that right there ought
to tell you that that's a little window
into god's heart right losing his own
child like that's the worst pain and a
window into satan's diabolical wicked
heart that he would even take out the
innocent children right
and so the next thing what happens right
so he shaves his head he goes down he
says you know what the lord giveth and
the lord takes away blessed be the name
of the lord i can imagine satan like
what
even after i took away his business even
after i slaughtered his children
he said blessed be the name of the lord
and so notice
he said after the death of his children
naked came i out of my mother's room and
naked shall i return the lord gave and
the lord has taken away was that a true
statement that's right
i think wait oh okay
oh was that a true statement i think i
think it is
he gave permission for it to be taken
away indirect but it's true
okay so does does does permission
mean
that uh how i would have phrased it if
my wife said you can cheat on me i still
wouldn't do it out of love even though
she gave me permission to do it it's
still my choice to do it so in the bible
what god allows i'm sorry in the bible
what god allows is attributed to god
yeah right because ultimately he's in
control
but
is he the cause of no
but what is that you think that was
that's what this text is saying i think
job
because think about it it's not only
proving
to satan that
who god is it's also proving to job who
god is that's right i would i that's
that's the comment i was going to make
was literally this is a window into how
much job really trusted god and he was
basically like look you have the ability
to give it or to take it away i don't i
don't necessarily think that he's
attributing what happened to him
from god but he's just like you're
everything you can do whatever you want
in the universe and so i'm just gonna
trust you
this has got to be some reason i can't
explain it yep but
hey the lord give us the lord take the
word but what do you say
blessed be the name of the lord
which is directly against what satan
said he was going to do he will curse
you to your face he takes everything
from him he goes no i'm blessing you
lord now listen to how it ends in all
this job what sin not send not nor
charge god foolishness love that there's
that verse that says be angry but since
it's not that
but it's the difference between reacting
to the situation in any normal human
reaction right and then sitting there
being angry at god and why did you do
this to me you know so now that's round
one so now let's look at chapter two
round two right so the bible says the
dragon the devil satan the serpent has
come down having what great wrath right
so notice satan is the accuser of their
brethren so so all these different names
of satan or of of the devil they
describe the attitude or the function
that he plays in the different roles
right so in this one he comes as satan
the accuser of the brethren right and so
satan is the accuser and satan answered
and said
skin for skin so he's now back in the
heavenly council right he says yay all
that a man has will he give for his life
he's like yeah i took away everything so
satan he does not stop no he was like
guess what but put forth your hand
no whose hand
your hand god now and touch his bone and
his flesh and he will what curse you to
your face and die and the lord said unto
satan behold he is in your hand so wait
did god give the permission who who is
actually doing the day right
so just because god allows it
it does not mean he's the one who's
actually doing it he says but but notice
satan he said put forth your hand did he
recognize whose authority
who has the ultimate authority who's
causing the pain who's caused it and
guess what satan could do nothing that
he had to ask permission exactly lord
can i same thing with the pigs
right can i
and the lord said yes
so you know what's interesting about
that is is even the devil respects that
god has the ultimate authority yes
only the sinful wicked heart of man
rejects that does job ever attribute his
suffering to satan because it seems like
he's just focusing completely on but he
doesn't know
he doesn't know what's going on in the
heaven heavenly councils but most people
would say like you know the lord taketh
and then you know how could he let satan
do this to me but he come he completely
focuses on god because he knows who's
the ultimate authority right right
so
now
guess what happens now the boils right
so the third way the first way
is financial problems the second way is
family problems and now the third way
that satan attacks god's people is
physical christ and probably the most
difficult oh yes right and he said hey
guess what a man will give anything for
his own life right and so notice job
chapter two what was satan's argument if
you take everything away what's he gonna
do now notice
it says then said his wife unto him
now
notice what she says
uh dost thou retain thine integrity
job are you sure there is no secret sin
in you i just want to point out people
love to doggone woman for this uh
this particular piece of the story i
just want to bring up remember when
jesus was talking to saying he said get
thee behind me i'm sorry jesus was
talking to peter and said get thee
behind me satan i think satan was
speaking through job's life
we're going there we're going there
we're going there we're going there so
that's my point that's why
listen that's why i prefaced this with
what was satan's argument
you will curse god and die now think
about it was job the only one who lost
something
no
who was going through this with him
do you think she was searching her heart
do you think that she was mourning the
death of all of her children all of her
so she's been with job this whole time
right so this is kind of like
god hardened pharaoh's heart or god soft
and moves his heart or whatever like the
same source as is no this is the depths
of pain will cause you to question
your faith
right so she's coming to him saying job
are you sure
there's nothing is there something that
i don't know
like are you holding anything from me
and what did she say
curse god and die and i i just want to
say this like just you know being
married and
i should probably be careful how i say
this but you know it really your your
wife is a big her opinion matters
absolutely and so you know the devil
knows it's like you're you're this unity
together and here's something that all
of a sudden you have this difference of
a of a perspective and how
how
that
spouse's opinion can be either really
hurtful and damaging or like you know i
mean that's that that was probably a
real testing point for job at this point
now we have to understand the the bible
is cyclical
did satan
tempt man through a woman before yeah
wow right so
when did sin enter into the world
when eve sinned or when adam said when
adam said so who's the responsible party
so no matter what my wife says isn't
that interesting ultimately the decision
is with me so it's not that the woman is
weak no i have to be her strength when
she doesn't have it i have to be for her
because he said your desire is unto your
husband right so i don't see her as
being weak i see her she's in pain and
she's questioning like what in the world
is going on job
and so satan in when did he come to
jesus at his weakest point after 40 days
right when he's delirious he's hungry so
at the weakest moment when did satan
come to job's wife
right and she began to well maybe joe
you know and so notice
whose voice was that
that wasn't her
right that was the enemy the voice of
satan
now notice job i love job
thou speakest as one of the foolish
women
what shall we receive good at the hand
of god and shall we not receive what
evil wait
the bible says god tempts no man
with evil so we have to understand that
job god is working on job simultaneously
because guess what fiery trials develop
our
faith
right and so when we go through these
trials and tribulations god is hey he
wants to perfect our faith
did jesus oh go ahead like
to continue he says in all this
didn't uh did not job sin with his lips
as if to say
we have a problem with what he's saying
but god is saying he doesn't like this
is not a sinful thing and we see the
progression throughout the book of job
how god works with john
in correcting his his thinking towards
god right amen wow were you there when i
created
my head right right so
notice in all this did not job sin with
his what his lips
lips so do you think he has some
internal struggles oh yeah
but he did not voice them right right
and so notice
job
constantly trusted in god right the lamb
was his uh only hope see the promises of
god were that guess what one day there's
going to be a lamb that takes away all
the sin of the world so what did jesus
teach concerning suffering and sickness
right so john 9 1-7 it says and jesus
passed by he saw a man which was blind
from his birth and his disciple asked
saying master who did
sin so what was their theology of
suffering there's a reason why right you
did something you did something that's
why you're blind basically you deserve
it now knows who do they blame this man
or his parent that he was born blind
jesus answered answered neither answered
neither has this man sinned nor his
parents but notice what he says
but for the works of god should be man
made manifest where
in him
so
i must work the works of him that sent
me while it is day the night comes when
no man can work so that man
was born blind because in god's infinite
mercy and wisdom he knew when jesus was
going to be born he knew jesus was going
to be walking by and he knew jesus was
going to work a miracle and where is
that miracle going to give glory to
god so you're saying sometimes god
allows the trials so that he can come up
so he can refine you and be a testimony
to all those come on you think he had he
had a testimony
absolutely
as long as i am in the world i am the
light of the world so then he heals him
he spat on the ground i love how he used
natural remedies right
and and
and and he made spittle and he anointed
the eyes of the blind man with the clay
and then he went and he washed and guess
what
there was a great go ahead there was
still an element of faith upon him
absolutely that it wasn't just the think
about it putting that on the eyes
it was like you've got to walk
by
there was no guarantee that first of all
he spat
like jesus didn't he could have said
eyes be open that's right but he was
intentional
about making this clay about and he had
a part to play in his own healing
right he had to exercise faith in jesus
who he never saw yeah that's a big
argument take up your mat and walk right
get it right you got to get up right you
want to be the leper who had to get in
the river yeah
yeah not too good oh is it going to work
right
he says go wash in the pool of saline
which is interpreted scent he went his
way therefore washed and what he came
seeing so what about paul's thorn in the
flesh right so sometimes god allows
suffering for his glory right now paul
writes
he had this thorn some people say it was
vision some people say it's other things
but notice what it says
uh we're going to second corinthians
chapter one verse three through seven so
paul has this thorn
and he says that satan
has come against him and this thorn
is buffeting him it's preventing him
from being uh what he's supposed to be
okay three through seven yeah second
corinthians three through seven grace be
to you and peace from god our father and
from our lord jesus christ blessed be
god even the father our lord jesus
christ the father of mercies and the god
of
all
comfort comfort it's highlighted right
uh who comfort us in all uh in all our
tribulation that we may be able to
comfort them
which are in trouble wow
yeah so so he allows us to go through
tribulations why
so that we can become a comfort to
someone guess what i can identify with
drug addicts
i know it's like i've slept in the
streets i've lost things so guess what
god he didn't will for me i chose that
for myself but even he says all things
work together for good to them that what
love the lord that's part of the
definition of being a christian others
focused he's pretty much equipping us to
live our christian life right so notice
the book of revelation revelation 14 uh
12 through 13. here is the patience
of the saints and that word patience is
hypominix and jupo minis is patient
under pressure i had a preacher heard a
preacher say okay everybody knows what a
twinkie is right
what's inside of a twinkie
some white stuff all right so
really unhealthy stuff right
and so when you put pressure
on the twinkie
what comes out the whites
so when satan puts pressure on the
christian
who comes out all that bad stuff is it
the character of christ
or is it
my character
right
and so pressure
this
it develops and guess what what you
really are is going to come out you can
hide it from man right but guess what
when the pandemic hit
there's a whole lot of divorces you know
why because people were in how like who
are you
i married you the kids are driving them
crate and guess what the pressure yeah
right and what does the pressure cooker
do if you have a slow cooker what does
it do
it speeds up the process
so tribulation speeds up the process
right and so it says here's the patience
of the saint here they that what keep
the commandments of god and have what
the faith of jesus but notice it doesn't
stop there would you read mikey and i
heard a voice from heaven saying unto me
right blessed are the blessed are the
dead which die in the lord from
henceforth oh you know there's a
blessing to those who die in the lord so
for the christian death is not
the the end
right the bible says that we sleep in
christ and it says the dead in christ
with what rise first right and so death
is not the end it says yay saith the
spirit that they may rest from their
what
laborers and their works do follow them
so question
what makes a perfect saint
someone who can be trusted under
pressure
because the bible did say
what type of man was job perfect he was
upright and perfect right so perfect
could we look at perfect meaning
spotless
none of us are perfect because we were
born and shaped in
sin iniquity right so the only one who's
ever been perfect is christ right so
perfection is not my perfection it's his
perfection on my behalf
that's justification then sanctification
is the process of me becoming like jesus
so james again
it says knowing this that the trying of
your faith works patience so
trying your faith produces what
patience
let now what's the word let me
aloud
allow
patience to have her what
so when we're going through trials god
is working
he's developing he's he's purifying
our characters so trials perfect the
saints so what kind of patience do the
saints have perfect patience whose
patience was perfect
jesus jesus right so
notice as we look at
what the bible teaches us we realize
that we are
in this war
notice
it says
in revelation 12 1-6 before the patience
of the saints there's there's a cosmic
battle going on it says there appeared a
great wonder in heaven a woman what's a
woman represent in bible prophecy
the church
right clove with the sun the moon under
her feet and she had what a head of 12
stars right and she being with child
travailing in birth pain to be delivered
and there appeared another wonder in
heaven behold a great what red dress red
dragon having seven heads and ten horns
and seven crowns upon his heads and his
tail drew a third part of the stars of
heaven and did cast him to the earth and
the dragon stood before the woman and
was ready to what
be delivered and what did he want to do
he wants to kill her so here it is now
first of all he lost in heaven i love
the fact the bible paints a picture that
satan is a loser
he lost in heaven
now he comes against job he loses
against job now in the last days he's
coming against a pregnant woman
and he still can't win
so who's really in control
you see jesus came to do battle with
satan he came to get victory over sin he
came to show us that satan is a loser
you don't want to be on the losing team
right and so this woman is a symbol of
god's church and then he's going to come
back for a pure church and guess what
she's going to be purified through
trials
notice
not churches
how many women
is god a polyamorous
no
there's only one church one faith one
lord and so the bible identifies this
church or hear the patience of the hear
the pains of the saints here they that
what
and
the faith of jesus the counterfeit of
god bringing his church into one unity
is the obviously the one world right
everybody pulling together that's the
devil's counterfeit so he's he's
watching what god's promising he's going
to do with his people and he's going oh
yeah watch this i'm going to make the
world all underneath one banner right
so
let's close with this it says and the
dragon was wrath of the woman and went
to make more war with what
the remnant of her seed which keep
the commandments of god and now it
changes and has the what testimony the
testimony of who jesus christ jesus
christ did jesus have a testimony
absolutely was he persecuted for his
testimony
and and linking it back to job how job
was like look i don't understand why
this is happening to me but i'm still
going to trust in you that's literally
what jesus said lord why have you
forsaken me but i'm going to trust in
you i don't understand why it feels like
you're not right there but i'm trusting
in you
so
let's look at the end of job because we
can't leave and say well what happened
to job
what about job like did god leave him in
that
barren state notice what the bible says
so the lord blessed the latter end of
job more than his beginning and he had
14 000 sheep 6 000 camels and
how many thousand yolk of oxy actually
he doubled
right and a thousand asses he also had
seven sons and three daughters after the
this liv joe lived job
140 years and saw his sons and his son's
sons even four generations
after this how long did he live
wow he saw four generations so job died
being old and what full of full of days
so did job go through some trials oh
yeah did he go through some tribulations
did he lose but did god restore
double
what he had lost did job vindicate the
character of god absolutely this is a
type
of the last
generation that remnant church of bible
prophecy that keep the commandments of
god and have or the testimony of jesus
and the faith of jesus so i hope that
this has answered this question for
people and i'm sure you might have other
questions but put it in the chat right
like we're here they're here to help you
find answers to life's biggest questions
there is no greater subject than to talk
about jesus and i thank you so much
london for blessing us with this talk
right here i hope you guys are blessed
as well and uh london how do people find
out more about you or your ministry so
you can go to
t-e-n-talents.org
and you can also go to
www.10timeswiser.com we have a
online school where we have on-demand
classes on many different subjects and
you guys can go there if you want to
support
our ministry everything goes to support
so that we can put more content like
that keep partnering with you guys and
other ministries also there's an app and
it's called american christian
ministries and you can download this app
it's 100 free and there's amazing
content on there and there's over 7
500 sermons on there seminars and
classes and so uh it is amazing and so
we want to make that resource available
to your audience awesome we'll put the
link in the description below and you
guys have some pretty awesome t-shirts
mikey tell us about the t-shirts so
these are cool t-shirts that london
designed because he used to be a
graffiti artist and now he gets to use
his talents the ten talents
for the lord and i just think it's
awesome because god doesn't take away
your dreams he
redirects them so that you can use them
to
expand the kingdom use them for eternal
good so check it out we've got a lot of
cool t-shirt designs um lightwear dot
shop and uh you guys can see some of
these designs popping out there and hey
if you got a great idea for t-shirts for
all year so thanks for supporting us
thanks for watching our shows and we'll
see you next week
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
is there any hope for me
what can i do to unify my family on not
watching harmful media how do i know my
thoughts are my own and how can i
distinguish between impressions from god
i'm nervous when it comes to sharing my
testimony that is really that important
i stopped watching mainstream media now
what sometimes we get a lot of people
asking the same kind of questions so we
thought it would be cool to make these
little videos answering some of them in
a new series called i got a question
concise answers to your media related
questions
we'd love to hear from you reach out to
us privately on our instagram page or
facebook
and if you don't use social media that's
all right send us an email through our
website little light studios dot tv
slash contact us
hey
we're here to help
we're here to help you
let your little light shine
[Music]
you